if Esther all I wanted to I wanted
actually you talked about how your
inspiration for the fast was was this
passage in Isaiah 58 and this motivated
you this this this was such a powerful
motivation for you that you were willing
to end your career over this you're
willing to do so many thought you know I
think this is going to put an end to
this whole this this whole Congress
thing all the good but I feel like I'm
doing here I'm only sacrifice any of
that going forward because i think this
this is really powerful and i'm going to
do this and then you went and and when
you told people about this and he said
you were doing this he said you didn't
tell them your motivation because you
you said that they would have thought
you're crazy the questions i have our
one can you envision a world and in
which you would have total and and and
to do you think that's a good place for
us to be i mean is that the direction it
seems to me that this class has kind of
it's kind of what we're talking about
it's getting to that sort of direction
where we can say my faith wants me to do
to you my faith motivates me to
alleviate poverty and i'm going to share
with you my faith based reasons as well
as my you know less faith based reasons
for alleviating poverty or for doing
something else good
I didn't when I had announced that I was
going to do this have a fast I didn't
say my inspiration was Isaiah 58 but
when asked why would I do this I I
didn't hesitate and I didn't want to I
didn't but I didn't I've seen so many
elected officials use faith in such a
way that it was odious to me and I
didn't want to be that but I would often
say people would also ask me not only in
my district but reporters and stuff I'd
say well turn off your camera let's talk
and then I would talk to him about faith
and I'd tell him you know my personal
belief and why so I never denied it and
matter of fact there were several
articles on it but only if asked because
I believe if you try to push faith and
religion down people's throats people
will run and they will get mad and and
it's it's not necessary because God is a
big guy he can take care of himself I
learned this lesson from my wife when I
first became a believer I tried to shove
my fate down her throat in that every
night I would say Jan would you like to
receive Jesus tonight
you can imagine how far this went and my
friends would come over and they'd say
Tony what's new and I said you're not
going to believe this but I I believe in
Jesus and oh my gosh and my wife would
kick me out of the table and everybody
would look up to the ceiling and my wife
said you're not going to have any
friends what do you are you a nutcase so
after six months of asking her she I
stopped because I was getting nowhere
and she was getting mad at me six months
later then she became a person of faith
after I said nothing I did nothing I
said why did you change she said because
when you stop preaching and speaking and
acting like a jerk I saw your life
change I saw your life changed towards
me your children towards your job said I
knew that was real and it was good and I
wanted that so I come at it by learning
this lesson from my wife that you don't
have to preach it you just hopefully you
show it and people will ask you they'll
say well what motivates you you know
they're always going to ask good